- I'm not gonna lie, I'm
gettin' a little nervous!
- This is my nightmare.
(Fatima and Brian laughing)
(intense music)
- We have an injury here!
(energetic dance music)
Wow, there's so many
beautiful people everywhere.
Okay, so this week,
we're in Miami, Florida!
I'm on my way to Juvia,
one of the best
restaurants in South Beach!
But first, let's make a quick stop,
to pick up Chef Sunny
Oh, in the 2017 RAV4!
Hey, what's up, Chef Sunny?
- What's goin' on?
- How ya doin'?
- I'm good, how are you?
- I'm doing good.
Nice to finally meet you!
- It's nice to meet you, too.
- Tell me a little bit about yourself.
- I was originally born in Korea.
Korean food is, without a
doubt, one of my favorite foods.
I remember watching my
mother, singing and cooking,
when I was a kid.
And she had great knife skills.
- Singing, cooking,
and great knife skills.
That's quite the triple threat.
Can you tell us a little bit about Juvia?
- [Sunny] Juvia has been
around for about five years,
bringing together a union of French ideas,
as well as Japanese,
and Peruvian influences.
- [Carl] What do we have in
store for our couples today?
- [Sunny] We have local black grouper.
Couples are gonna have fun
with some knife techniques,
and it should be light, and healthy.
(piano party music)
- [Carl] Hello, everyone.
My name is Carl Monroe,
and I am your host.
Welcome to Tasty Date Night!
(crowd cheering)
Today, we're here, in South Beach,
to watch as two couples
put their relationship,
and culinary skills,
through the ultimate test,
in a cooking showdown.
Whoever impresses our judge the most,
can look forward to a
romantic date night out,
here, at Juvia.
(crowd cheering)
Our first couple have been
together for 17 years!
Please, help me welcome, Brian and Fatima!
(crowd cheering)
- We love all different kinds of foods.
So, then, we like to
experiment with new recipes
all the time.
- And I'm Spanish, and Cuban,
so I like to bring in a little
extra mix, a little flair!
- A lotta times, when we
cook, we cook together.
- I'm not gonna lie.
(Brian laughing)
He likes to own the
kitchen space, totally!
- There's some things I
just don't do well, though.
And she jumps in, and
takes care of all of those.
- It would be awesome to win a date night.
We're always working.
It's not everyday we get to
go out, to a nice restaurant,
alone, together.
- Right.
It will force us to go.
(needle scratches)
- (laughs) Force you?
- No, it will force us, together, to go.
- Our second couple have only
been together for one year.
Please help me welcome, Nico and Felicia!
(crowd cheering)
- We cook together, a lot, on Sundays.
I kinda let him take over,
and I'd, like, drink the wine,
and say, like, that looks
good, and that looks great!
I don't cook, but I like to eat! (laughs)
- And I like to cook, and I'm
Italian, so I have to cook!
You're nervous.
- Yeah, I'm nervous about the
knives, and the hot plates.
I think I'm gonna ruin it for him.
- I think we'll do good.
We're a good team.
High five!
- Okay! (laughs)
- Well, we wish you all the best of luck
in today's competition.
Our chef, and judge
for today, Juvia's own,
Chef Sunny Oh!
(crowd cheering)
How are ya doin', Sunny?
What are our couples
gonna be cooking today?
- Local, line-caught black grouper.
- Let's see if that looks
as good as it sounds!
(groovy chill music)
Alright, couples, watch carefully,
because you are going to cook this.
Yummy, pomegranate.
- [Sunny] Farro is one
of the oldest grains.
- [Carl] I think of it as
like, large brown rice.
Looks like you're gonna
be using that knife a lot!
(exclaims) Tasty!
Alright, couples!
You have 30 minutes, to
cook, and plate this dish!
Without further ado,
let's put 30 minutes on the clock, please!
Let's get tasty!
(crowd cheering)
(energetic music)
- No pressure, guys!
- This is horrible.
- Spank it, spank it!
- Thanks, Nico!
- I gotta bang it, people!
I gotta bang it!
I spent ten minutes tryin'
to get pomegranate seeds
outta the pomegranate.
- Good job!
Turn that (expletive) up to ten.
Damn.
(Fatima groaning)
- Oh, oh my God!
- Splashdown!
- You got pomegranate juice all over me.
- [Felicia] Sorry, baby!
- I mean, that's, that's
good enough, right?
- Lunch, brought to you today,
by the Good Enough Cooking Company!
- Alright, Sunny.
So, what is the most
important step to execute,
in order to win today?
- I think they need to get
that grouper into the oven
as quickly as possible.
You know, give it some
color, and then get in,
because that's probably gonna
take the most amount of time.
- [Nico] I hope I'm
doing everything right.
- [Felicia] Whatever.
It's too late now.
- The grade of this
table is a little higher.
- I know, I'm too tall.
- [Felicia] Okay, I'm done!
- [Carl] I'm not gonna lie,
I didn't know that's how you
get pomegranate seeds out.
- [Fatima] Yum!
- It looks great.
- [Felicia] Watch it.
It's gonna burn.
- Brian, you're good at this.
- I'm looking at it, and it
looks like you're gonna burn it.
- [Nico] Am I forgetting something?
- [Felicia] Put that in the oven now.
- (exclaims) That's a little hot!
I focused on the fish!
- Now, the hot stuff.
- Out of the hot stuff!
- [Brian] Hot, goin' behind.
Comin' in hot!
Don't mix 'em up, chef!
Don't steal my fish!
- Steal your fish?
I don't know which one it is!
- He's doing everything!
You got this! (laughs)
- In Japanese technique,
there's the style of cutting,
it's not just about cutting the product,
it's how you cut it, the size of it.
The cucumber, the pomegranate,
the hearts of palm,
wanna remain to be about the same size.
- I hope I don't cut myself.
- [Felicia] You're doing fine.
(Nico exclaiming)
- Water for our cover.
- [Fatima] Water for our what?
- [Brian] Cover it.
I did the fish, made the sauce.
- Alright, it looks like we
are just about to approach
the 20-minute mark!
- Is there a wrong way to peel this?
- We need to get this pan
hot enough for the asparagus.
- Interesting fact about white asparagus,
is that it's just grown in the dark,
and that's why it's white.
- The fish is done.
- Great!
Can you do the other stuff, too?
- Look at my thumb!
(Nico laughing)
- I can't.
- You read it through?
We're not missin' anything?
- [Fatima] I don't think so.
Maybe I should read the directions.
(Fatima and Brian laughing)
- Famous last words, read the recipe.
- [Felicia] If you wouldn't...
You have to put salt in that.
I think I, like, diced
everything, pretty nicely.
- Oh, did you put the timer on?
- Yeah, that's for the fish.
- [Felicia] There are things
that you could be doing,
I'm sure.
- [Brian] Delicious!
- (exclaims) Butter!
- I'm not worried about
just cutting my finger.
- Brian and Fatima, how are you two doing?
- I think we're right on track here.
I think we're gonna put out a nice meal.
We gotta make the chef proud.
- Nico and Felicia, how are you two doing?
- Pretty good, I guess.
I mean, I'm still alive,
after cutting my thumb.
- Oh, my, dramatic.
He's dramatic.
It is fine.
- Let's make some noise
for these couples, y'all.
(crowd cheering)
- Oh, my God.
We only have ten minutes!
(Fatima exclaiming)
- Did you set it right,
or you set it wrong?
- No, I did it right.
- You went this way?
Is it moving?
I don't think it's movin'.
- When I put that on, it went off.
So, I was just sittin' there,
and now, I'm like, oh,
oh yeah, turn that on.
Ready?
(timer bell ringing)
- [Felicia] Turn that off.
- [Nico] I'll be right back!
- Bye, miss you already.
- [Fatima] With some flair.
- I like this, though.
- It's lookin' pretty good!
- [Brian] A little bit of pepper on that.
- No, I didn't.
- I'm not allowed to do the cooking part.
- [Nico] No, what am I doing?
I know!
- Top it off.
- [Fatima] I thought it was broken.
- [Brian] It'll break up.
- Can you, I can, but I
need you to come back,
'cause I don't know what to do.
- That should be a little chewy.
- Another minute.
- One minute.
I'm just getting hungry, you know?
- I only slipped, like,
six times in the kitchen.
- Alright, y'all, two minute warning!
- We're doing good.
I think we're almost ready to go!
- We're outta bowls.
- We put the farro,
then we put the grouper.
Isn't the fish, go on top of it?
- [Brian] The fish leans on one side it,
and then, the watercress goes in the hole.
- Seems like a good ratio there.
- We're gonna make this look sexy.
(Felicia snickering)
You put the farro first, and
then we'll put the asparagus,
kinda lean over like, like
the beautiful video was.
Looks good with the cress,
make it look real nice.
- I will.
- How many asparagus, do we?
- Yeah.
- Let's rapido.
- [Nico] Yeah.
- [Felicia] Well, put it in there.
- Oh, I think I put
one too many asparagus.
- [Carl, Sunny and Crowd]
Ten, nine, eight, seven, six,
five, four, three, two one!
- [Carl] Time, time!
Look at this good
sportsmanship going on here!
Now, turn to your partner,
and give them a hug!
That was so intense!
Aw, I seen that little kiss, Felicia!
(crowd cheering)
Up first, we have Brian and Fatima.
- There ya go, chef!
That was a little crazy!
The 30 minutes goes by a lot
faster than you think it does.
It was a little stressful.
I did a lot of dicing, with
all of my fingers still intact.
- I'mma let Chef Sunny go ahead,
and take a first bite, here.
And I'm just gonna copy what he does.
I'll have you hold the mic.
- Alright.
Well cooked.
Nice balance.
Done well.
(quiet, intense music)
- This is really good!
- [Sunny] It's a nice balance.
The fish was cooked well.
You can take the butteriness of the fish,
the pomegranate, cucumber,
and the hearts of palm
seem like it balanced well
with no amount of frothiness in it.
Good job.
- Thank you.
- Thank you!
- I'm pretty convinced
that we've won this.
- (laughs) I hope so!
- Unless somebody switched
the fish in the oven,
when I couldn't see it.
- I think we made it look pretty.
I hope we did the chef justice!
- Let's go ahead and bring
out Nico and Felicia.
- Bon appetit.
Feel good.
It was a whirlwind!
- Still, like, processing.
I just tried to stay out of his way.
I cut the cucumbers.
I peeled the asparagus.
You know, just like things,
like a small child would do,
I did.
And I think I did them adequately.
- While Chef Sunny is trying
some of this, let me ask,
what did you two struggle with?
- I think, making the time
work, as far as the fish,
and the farro, and boiling everything,
and putting on the seasonings.
And that was the toughest part.
(calm music)
- Very good.
- Well done.
Yep, well done, well balanced.
I think the fish was cooked well.
Good job.
- Thank you.
- Good job!
I think we're gonna win.
You think we're gonna win?
- I think so.
- I think we're gonna win.
- Alright.
So, that was really fun.
- Important thing about this dish,
is the balance of
everything coming together,
the fish being cooked properly,
the components, and the
elements, coming together,
with the proper amounts.
First couple, the fish
was cooked very well.
Some of that stood out for me.
I think their cuts were a
little on the small side.
Nico and Felicia's fish seemed
like it had a little bit more
of a crust to it.
So, they gave it a little
more time to sit there,
and Chris bowed on the pan,
before they put it in the oven.
I like the cuts of the cucumber,
and heart of palm, were bigger.
There seemed to be a little
bit more watercress there.
And so, it helped tie it together well.
- Do you think that we
have a definitive winner?
- I do.
- Alright, well, let's go
ahead, and announce the winner.
(crowd cheering)
Welcome back!
That was so fun!
Both couples did wonderful.
But, let's get to it.
Drum roll, please?
The winner...
Of Tasty Date Night: Miami...
Is...
- Nico and Felicia.
(crowd cheering)
- Congratulations to both couples!
- Good!
- I feel good, I feel good.
- We feel good. (laughs)
- I feel good, now.
- We win!
- I feel good, now!
Before, I was like...
- It was a cool recipe.
So, whoever came up with it...
- Yeah,
I would've never thought to
put any of that together.
- The fish was tasty.
- It was tasty.
That was funny.
- The whole experience was beautiful.
See you at the all-star game.
I love you.
- Ew, my nose!
- [Brian Voiceover] I
mean, it was a great day.
Great day, good competition.
We didn't win, but we had
a great time doin' it.
And we had a good plan, going into it.
We stuck to it, and we
played well off each other.
- Yeah, totally.
We're very proud of ourselves.
- Thank you so much, to Juvia.
Thank you, to the city of Miami,
and the amazing audience here!
This has been Tasty Date Night,
brought to you by Toyota!
(crowd cheering)
Good job, you guys!
That was amazing!
Amazing!
(energetic party music)